[Music]
um so obviously everybody usually goes
to the happiest place on earth a lot of
people have romantic relationships and
attachment to this place so
so people want to
i know
um once you propose there and this is a
recent proposal that happened at
[ __ ] me
is there a guy dumping ashes in the
background
disneyland uh
paris this is disneyland paris okay here
we go cause i was gonna say that castle
looks a little different which castle is
that
[Music]
oh i like this one it's hilarious
she's gonna know
excuse me no no no you cannot do this
here
please down here please there's a
message
listen
yes that's great
here she's gonna be even better
he should have decked him in the [ __ ]
face wait what is he he was trying to
say
stand here instead because it looks
better because they're not allowed to be
on that platform but even though the the
dude asks for permission yeah i heard he
asked a different worker like hey can i
propose my girlfriend on this like
little stage area and the work said yeah
go ahead do it and someone else like a
whole monitor came up like no you gotta
do here should have beat his [ __ ] ass
he like took the ring
that's a bit much yeah he's like hey the
rule is that i get to beat your ass yeah
yeah and he grabbed the ring that was
crazy that isn't that [ __ ] wild yeah
is that the most french thing you've
ever seen
is this why nobody likes a french this
is why this is one of the reasons why
one of the [ __ ] laundry list reasons
but this just went
nobody likes the french or the french
don't like us the french doesn't like
anybody and nobody likes the french yeah
they're kind of rude apparently all the
people that i know that have traveled to
to france yeah they always come back
with a story of like the reason
they smell touch the mona lisa
i was just bringing cake
you can't throw a cake at a [ __ ] guy
you can't even throw a cake trying to
let her eat it you know dude that guy
[ __ ] sucks
that guy has never had sex in his life
he's miserable yeah yeah that guy that
guy was wearing mickey mouse ears that
are glittery for that he should be alone
for the rest of his life yeah so
disneyland paris uh apologizes after
this uh clip goes viral and stuff the
employee swoops in to ruin the proposal
uh yes just like you know obviously
obviously you guys put the details out
this guy did ask for permission he was
actually going to propose later on that
night but the the feels just hit him he
just felt like it was the right time
when it's right it's right the ring's
burning a hole in your pocket that's
right though yeah the ring was burning a
hole in the [ __ ] loser ruined it the
the thing that i don't get is why did
that employee think that it was
necessary to interrupt at that moment
and stop it instead of like waiting just
a minute or two yeah because he's an
idiot does he want he wanted to make it
about himself that's interesting
he's like
that was a greater good that he had to
uphold which was mickey mouse's rules
you know mickey mouse had rules to not
do this yeah or maybe he proposed to a
girl from publicly before and he got
rejected
this guy the pain
of being rejected what a hero
and he's like no like he saw his the
flashback of him at like disney world in
florida proposing to his girlfriend and
she's like no and then she left him i
actually heard that
mickey mouse right he could see a note
coming this is an anti-hero who just
said no story oh who's to say no to me
but what have you ever been proposed to
cat huh yeah i have really yeah but she
said [ __ ] you no he said yes but i don't
think the proposal was for me it was for
him
because uh he and i had been together
for so many years and he was really
prominent at this like church camp thing
and he was aging out of being a
counselor this is last year there and he
always had this childhood dream of
proposing to his girlfriend at this like
church camp event and so i jesus because
it was his last year and i knew he was
going to propose to me no one else knew
but like i was there and i just kind of
stood around like all of his church
friends
like
and i said yes and then like we broke up
afterwards so you were from church camp
to porn star yeah
like awesome but it's funny because the
porn star is more like sentimental and
like yeah more wholesome and much more
like i don't know he cares more about
what i want than like what he wants he
wants a connection and this guy wants a
he wants to be a superstar
at church
dude the religious the outwardly
religious people are the [ __ ]
dirtiest ass freaks too
what you've been through no i'm
outwardly religious
and i'm very kinky
he's the leader of the jesus camp and
he'd be funny and if there's one thing
about jesus camps they [ __ ] yeah it's
orgy camp yep
they mean butt cheeks thank you i heard
a strong eyelid i heard mickey mouse
don't play around though if you work for
disney that was like a mobster
like he'll just be like
you wanna propose
at disneyland do you
well you're gonna pay a fee
if you don't i'm gonna get you that by
the way is a spot on south park disney
disney yeah yeah south southbound mickey
mouse mickey that's a good mix
for sure
i think that's a good regular mickey
dude yeah that episode was gangsta
mickey mouse is a thug yeah yeah
south park episode was like one of the
craziest things i've ever seen on tv
it was the craziest thing i had seen
until i was in the lizard gang rape
video on jk news
yeah that was pretty good inspired by
south park yo that guy that swooped up
the ring i think he would be one of the
four guys that was gonna gang rape oh
yeah because that guy the fourth one of
the four guys that guy has some weird
[ __ ] under it and he's in charge of
getting the monitor down from yeah yeah
yeah
that guy's a weirdo bro i bet you you
you investigate him you're gonna find
some do you think he deserves a firing
he deserves a [ __ ] stone cold stunner
i remember because there was like
they were saying that like a lot of
people were like oh he's just doing his
job and then i remember they did an
interview with like another disney
employee and they were like was he
really doing his job and she was like uh
yes and no where like if someone they
said if someone's starting to do a
proposal and it happens every day you're
supposed to let it happen and then you
can address like after it's done then
you're done you can after the moment's
done you go okay guys come down from
there now please like but you have to
like let the moment ride out and you 100
don't grab their belongings yeah yeah
like so she was like saying explaining
that uh he should get fired because
that's so much bad pr for disney and
they [ __ ] hate that they look like
[ __ ] but that's french disney
they're different bad pr for the country
of france i guess but it's still the
brand of disney yeah like it still comes
back to you know disney as a whole this
isn't one of those like uh
tokyo disney type things where it's like
outside of that it's like a franchise
it's not actually walt disney
you want to talk about yeah no it's
actual disney no all of them are
licensed they're all right they're all
real dudes but are we people one one in
japan is not
i think we're kind of ignoring something
yeah one of us
we're ignoring well we're americans
right so to us this is very rude but in
paris they see this article like in the
paper or something they're like oh good
good good
little happy things yeah with their
cigarettes and their little extenders
yeah yeah because i heard that the
um the paris disneyland is actually ran
by pepe le pew and not mickey see that
that's different that's still different
and he's got a shady pass that guy yeah
oh dude he's groping
can a cartoon ip get like cancelled i
think he did actually i don't think he
was in space jam too
wasn't he just like he just was reduced
to it being an extrovert
yeah they put him in aquaman too
i wonder if i just had a lot of cool
characters like that there was a tiny
toon character called foul mouth do you
remember that guy he just used to cuss a
shitload but they would just like bleep
what he says like you could never get
away with that if you wanted to see them
they were like the bad boys of cartoon
right if you want to see them you go to
universal studios
if you want to if you want to be a [ __ ]
for a day you go to disneyland
that's the dippy [ __ ] for a day we
could buy pepe le pew from disney
because they're not going to use it how
much do you think they'd uh like take
for him that's what i'm saying what's
going on because they're not going to
use them anymore
i don't know i just said that i think
everything is not that he's a warner
character really it probably is because
i said space jam so yeah good point
but you know they don't want to shuffle
so he's like a six flex character yeah
we'll take them oh wait is it is it
universal or is it six flags that does
the warner brother character i think six
flags has like bugs bunny and stuff
right yeah yeah dude six five also has
the old man character that dances
i think so because it's a young man i
think it's a young man in an old man
it's like an old man max yeah do you
guys remember um for six flags that if
you bought a ticket and you brought a
can of coke
you had a free extra ticket the glory
days
and you guys remember at ralph's you
were able to buy an annual ticket to six
flags and it was like 60 bucks yeah 60
bucks me and my friends all bought it
and then we never went because we never
got a ride yeah
yeah you gotta go all the way to the
balloon because we're just like nobody
wants you out there i get this and then
one you know we could go as much time as
we want right and then we bought it and
then we'll be like hey can you drive us
we ask our parents can you drive us to
six flags i'm like [ __ ] no and all of
our parents didn't drive us like [ __ ]
that's cause even the president's 65 i
was like god damn i gotta drive to
[ __ ] valencia
six flags like this is [ __ ] blow and
then he goes to disneyland instead yeah
he's like it's closer it's just closer
you can park easier
can't propose though yeah
i think everybody bought a six flags
season password never win yeah because
it was just it was almost the same price
as a regular day pass or you get upsell
to like hurricane harbor never go to
that either oh i never even saw the
inside of the place is it any good what
a water park water parks are awesome
i love them except they're all just like
children's urine nowadays did nuts used
to have one or do yeah so silk city yeah
is it still operating yeah i think so
just nice to go there huh yeah as a kid
just saying so he makes me laugh because
i'm a [ __ ] child
what do you mean
i think about a woman just sitting there
getting all turned on and [ __ ]
i think you're gonna explain it so
literally yeah and she's all turned on
[ __ ] at soap city and [ __ ] i'm just
thinking about a woman getting turned up
i'm surprised i didn't make that joke
that's an entry fee that's it
that's what we call anthony lee dude
he's so excited she gets two legs
that's what we call anthony lee anthony
silk city
it's like it's just like you know what
it says in the quarter of like where
newscast is like they're in dubai yeah
so it's like anthony lee it's just so
sick
usa
yeah when they see anthony lee they're
just like oh so it's
got it so it's really we just have girls
you trigger horniness yeah this video's
over and lizard lizard gang rape
trigger warning
for the ladies
[Music]
[Music]
you